hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
Erickson mcus will conclude his speech
praising love in the symposium and has
run through the many different arts by
culminating in talking about loves role
no longer just in the human body or in
music but throughout the entire cosmos
and there's some interesting plays on
words involved with the term cosmos that
I'll talk about in just a moment so just
to recap good love in Erik Simha kisses
view is some sort of Concorde or harmony
or ordering of opposites that well
leaving them opposite opposed to each
other
manages to bring them together in a
greater unity bad love is instead the
discord of those allowing them to sort
of break down into their their
antagonisms and so we can we can
contrast good love and bad love to each
other not only in terms of medicine but
also in terms of gymnastics in terms of
music in terms of all these different
ways in which it plays itself out he's
going to say that the same basic
elements of you know the human body
namely the the hot and the cold the wet
and the dry all these physical aspects
of things are
in the entire cosmos are present in the
entire world of our experience going
beyond as the bodily or the societal
looking to the heavens looking to the
earth everything that's below it all of
these complex systems that are going on
with the weather everything is
ultimately working with the same
repertoire of elements he thinks so what
that means is if there's going to be an
analogy between medicine and all of
these larger scale activities and
systems and the arts that deal with them
he talks about the seasons of the year
and he says that with respect to these
elements there can be a harmony or a
disharmony I'm gonna read a little bit
from this because he's got such
interesting stuff that he says says when
the regulating principle of love brings
together these opposites hot and cold
wet and dry and compounds them in an
ordered harmony the result is health and
Plenty for mankind and for the animal
and vegetable kingdoms and all goes as
it should health not only for the human
body as a unit but health for the human
race as a whole at least in that part of
the world where things are going alright
same thing for the animals same things
for the plants when the seasons are
going as they want to of course you know
the animals are eating some of the
plants and some of the plants are
probably preying on each other and
animals are eating each other and human
beings are eating both the animals of
the plants but he understands this is
sort of a an ordered system in which you
know things are able to grow and succeed
the way that they ought to now it's very
different when things are not going as
they should he says when the seasons are
under the influence of that other love
the love that brings about discord the
love that goes too far the love that
allows the opposites to break down into
their antagonisms he says all his
mischief and destruction for now plague
and disease of every kind attack both
herds and crops that affects not only
those particular animals but also the
larger
ecosystem in ribbon which they're
involved and the human beings who are
dependent upon them he says not only
these but frost and hail and blight
these these sort of weather phenomena if
he was living in the United States he'd
probably say tornadoes as well you know
but but I don't think they had too many
of those back then all of them are due
to the uncontrol than the acquisitive in
that great system of love and who
actually is able to not and not modify
what's going on but at least get you
know some idea about what's coming up
the astronomer and he uses us this word
aster oh no Meah literally the laws of
the stars the the you know workings the
systemic workings of the celestial realm
from which we get all these weather
phenomena he also talks about the gods
and it's important to remember that for
the ancient Greeks the gods were
themselves part of the cosmos they were
incredibly powerful forces within the
cosmos who are sometimes identified with
particular regions or particular
phenomena so for example the lightning
bolt was understood as Zeus's weapon by
which he would punish people you know
earthquakes are identified with Poseidon
who is also the god of the sea
you know the growing of the crops has
identified both with Demeter and her
daughter Persephone the reason why crops
end up dying and everything goes goes
you know bad during winters could be
Persephone is going down into the earth
and we can go on and on and on with this
the Greeks personified the winds they
had all sorts of things along these
lines every single creek or stream had
its own you know a little little deity
involved but here's the key point that
Erik Semak is is making there is a
possible communion a Koinonia and this
is an important term MacLean Omiya means
a commonality or a sharing a you might
even say community between human beings
and the divine this is the way he sees
it the way things ought to be but it's
not something that necessarily is going
to be the case just like with the
the weather it could be the good law
that's predominating but it can also be
the bad love and we don't have a lot of
control over that the same thing can
happen between human beings in the
divine but we actually have a bit more
control over that because we have two
arts the art of sacrifice and the art of
divination divination by the way doesn't
just mean some occult phenomena you know
that's what we often think of it today
it's literally trying to find out what
the will of the Gods is what the gods
want to say to us so you know things are
going wrong you go to the diviner to
find out well why is Zeus mad at me how
can I make things right how can I
restore this Koinonia this communion
between the human and the divine so the
two arts might work together their
sacrifice and divination the point of
them like I put here is to restore or to
preserve something and Eric's images
calls this love preserving or restoring
the love that has been lost they kind of
harmony a kind of order remember how he
sees good love and he says something
really interesting here to sort of bring
this to a close he says that impiety so
banty actions towards the guys that then
tends to disrupt this harmony that takes
the gods off impiety stems from
indulging unhealthy love what we might
call a lower level so what you know what
causes impiety he says most of our
impiety springs from our refusal to
gratify the more temperate love to
follow the order of things to actually
keep all the opposites in harmony with
each other and he goes on and he says to
gratify this more temperate love to the
respect and defer to him and everything
we do and from our following that other
love in our attitude towards who towards
our parents parents are considered to be
in a certain respect for the ancient
Greeks semi-divine they occupy this
status that's you know in between the
you know the purely human and the divine
why because they provided one with the
principle of life and so they're
responsible for one's very being or
exist
and impiety extends to not only the gods
but also to one's parents as a result
what would lead somebody not to do that
well it could be that they've got a
disordered soul in which case music or
medicine might be the thing to affect
that so he says it's the diviners of
office to be the guide in healer of
these laws and his art of divination
with its power to distinguish between
those principles of human law that tend
to decency and reverence is in fact the
source of time chord between God and man
so what we're left with an Erich Simha
Kisses view is we've got the human body
itself which is worked on by medicine in
which good and bad love can exist
hopefully the the bad love is driven out
the good love is created we have music
also working on on the soul we have all
these other arts and then finally we
have the entire cosmos which can be if
not it worked upon at least understood
by certain arts analogous to those of
medicine seeing everything in terms of
good and bad love that that has to apply
to jarring or discordant elements that
are opposed to each other